et avec nous pour ce club des
territoires Arnaud Benedetti bonjour
Arnaud merci d'être la rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
le politologue Bruno coqueresse nous a
rejoins bonjour Bruno merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et c'est vendredi c'est
Quentin bonjour Quentin bienvenue dans
ce club on parlera avec vous de
l'actualité de la semaine marqué par la
violence envers les élus le personnel
soignant les forces de l'ordre est-ce
une des civilisations de la société
comme l'a dit Emmanuel Macron et puis le
Sénat va se pencher sur l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty Quentin vous nous direz tout
y a-t-il eu défaillance de l'État il y
aura peut-être une commission d'enquête
vous me le direz dans quelques instants
et puis l'actualité politique de la
semaine a été marquée par ce bras de fer
entre majorité présidentielle et
opposition autour du texte qui vise à
abroger la réforme des retraites la
majorité peut-elle empêcher le débat
l'opposition peut-elle réussir à faire
passer ce texte on verra ça dans
quelques instants d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Besançon où on retrouve Romuald
pontzoni bonjour Romuald merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeurs
départemental de l'Est Républicain dans
le Doubs vous allez nous parler du lynx
oui c'est la bonne nouvelle du jour et
l'histoire de deux lynx qui ont été
rendus à la vie sauvage de lynx qui ont
été recueillis très jeunes dans un état
de santé vraiment déplorable et puis de
lynx ont été retapées pendant 6 mois
dans un centre à militaire cueillir les
animaux blessés c'est le centre athénès
de l'étoile dans le Jura et au bout de
au bout de 6 mois voilà ces deux lynx
qui ont été baptisés le pour le mal ou
Willy et pour la femelle phrase ont été
relâchés hier dans la rue massif dans le
massif du Jura voilà donc pendant un an
ces deux animaux vont être espionnés
c'est un bien grand mot mais voilà suivi
par par les bénévoles du centre pour
pouvoir comprendre leur mode de vie leur
fonctionnement pouvoir
connaître leur mode d'alimentation leur
leur façon de se déplacer tout cela
entre dans un cadre aussi de un plan
d'action en faveur de l'espèce en
l'occurrence le lynx un animal qui est
hyper protégé parce qu'il est il fait
partie de la liste des animaux
qui sont extrêmement menacés donc il y a
une extrême vigilance pour pour ce type
d'animaux
national qui est mis en place pour
protéger le lynx c'est ça romual oui
c'est ça c'est un plan qui va permettre
justement de te préserver
on rappelle que beaucoup de langues
seront sont détruits par la main de
l'homme malheureusement par le
braconnage et je rappelle que m'a tué
une espèce protégée en particulier à
lynx boréal pardon
on a pour une peine de prison maximale
de 3 ans et jusqu'à 150 000 euros
d'amende et puis l'autre problème c'est
l'urbanisation c'est les routes ce sont
bah c'est le trafic sur les routes et
puis beaucoup de beaucoup de ces
individus sont entre en cohésion avec
des trains avec des voitures sans
écrasées donc voilà il y a il y a un
vrai un vrai plan d'action qui a été qui
a été déployé en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
et pour la petite anecdote
sous certaines panneaux sous certains
pardon panneaux d'entrée de sortie de
communes sont empêcher des petits pictos
attention lynx voilà et l'autre belle
histoire de ces lynx c'est que le centre
athénase justement vient de recueillir
un autre petit lynx qui va être retapé
remis sur pattes pour pouvoir être
prochainement relâcher et retourner dans
son milieu naturel merci
[Musique]
des deux courriers en calendrier
président Larcher au président aussi la
commission des lois vous le disiez rien
elle demande l'ouverture je cite encore
d'une enquête parlementaire afin
d'établir les failles de ce drame et de
tenter d'en colmater les brèches alors
dans un premier temps mercredi j'ai un
chat souhaité que soit examiné avec
attention et empathie respectueuse la
demande d'ouverture du commission
d'enquête on en était un peu là jusqu'à
hier effectivement sur notre antenne le
président et l'air de la commission des
lois et bien il va encore plus loin il
fait cette annonce écoutez François Noel
buffet notre micro
nous allons réfléchir à la façon de
répondre aux favorablement à sa demande
car effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
laisser une famille dans l'ignorance en
tous les cas nous avons besoin d'avancer
donc nous allons prendre des initiatives
très rapidement je pense dès la semaine
prochaine donc je vais bien lui répondre
naturellement vous nous la lancez au
micro publics il y aura bien une
commission d'enquête sur l'assassinat de
Samuel il y aura tous les cas si ce
n'est une commission d'enquête un moyen
de pouvoir éclaircir la situation ça
s'appelle la commission d'enquête ça
s'appellera mission nous allons le
déterminer vous savez qu'il y a des il y
a des conditions à tout cela mais bien
sûr qu'il faut répondre à sa demande
principale difficulté pour les sénateurs
c'est ne pas empiéter sur l'enquête
judiciaire qui est en cours en vertu un
de la séparation des pouvoirs on le
rappelle les parlementaires doivent se
concentrer sur les défaillances des
pouvoirs publics ne doivent pas poser de
questions sur des faits pénalement
répréhensibles le scénario décidera dans
les prochaines semaines la forme de
cette enquête alors cela devrait
attendre la nouvelle session a priori en
octobre prochain sur Assas sur l'antenne
bien sûr et on suivra bien sûr tout ça
parce que des questions se posent
toujours elles ont été remises en
lumière par la sœur de sur la
responsabilité de l'État dans
l'assassinat de ce professeur et
d'éventuelles défaillances de la part de
l'État oui manifestement si vous voulez
les 10 jours qui ont précédé ce terrible
assassinat ont quand même été
extrêmement compliqué on le voit on le
sait on a quand même quelques
informations qui ont filtré depuis
maintenant plus de plus de plus de
presque deux ans donc moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose en l'occurrence
parce que manifestement c'est quand même
un enseignant qui a été laissé un peu à
découvert c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il y avait des menaces depuis
plusieurs jours qui planait sur sa
sécurité on a vu quand même que il a été
très moyennement défendu à l'époque on
lui a dit oui mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment nécessaire de faire ses courses
sur les caricatures donc il y a eu des
flottements manifestement il y a eu des
flottements et tout ce qui peut faire
quand même mettre en lumière les
éventuels de fonctionnement non
seulement c'est important pour la
famille c'est important de sa mémoire
mais c'est aussi important pour que ça
ne se renouvelle pas par la suite c'est
que on puisse disons mettre en place des
process de j'allais dire de protection
des personnels enseignants qui soient
infaillibles c'est tenté que ça soit
possible ça rejoint toute la
problématique dans laquelle on est
depuis un moment et particulièrement ces
derniers jours qui est la responsabilité
de l'État par rapport à ces personnel
enseignants soignants policiers
on avait vu la le cas du maire aussi
démissionnaires voilà qui lui aussi a
rendu compte de ce sentiment un peu de
se retrouver tout seul les au bord de la
route et c'est vrai que les enseignants
ils ont aussi souvent ce sentiment qui
sont un peu en première ligne et un peu
démuni et en manque de soutien donc ça
rejoint un sujet qui va donner je pense
un sujet très important dans les mois 40
ans il y a les enseignants vous le
disiez
sous protection policière il faut le
rappeler suite à un livre qu'elle vient
de publier sur
les Frères musulmans peut-être un
dernier mot sur Samuel Paty le collège
où travaillait où on saigné Samuel Paty
ne porte toujours pas son nom
contrairement à ce qui avait été promis
lorsqu'il a été assassiné qu'est-ce que
ça révèle ça une forme de crainte ça
révèle que les pouvoirs publics ont le
bras qui tremble très clairement parce
que il me semble tout à fait naturel que
ce collège porte le nom de cette de cet
enseignant qui est quand même martyre
donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
surprenant que plus de deux ans c'est ça
c'est plus de 2 ans maintenant octobre
2020 c'est à dire presque 3 ans
maintenant que il n'y ait pas eu
finalement une suite qui était donnée à
ce qui me paraît être une demande tout à
fait naturelle et légitime
oui très clairement on ne comprend pas
très bien effectivement pour quelle
raison
battant aussi longtemps
sans d'ailleurs sans aucun doute il y
aura des initiatives à ce moment-là si
le collège ne porte pas son nom d'autres
établissements peut-être voudront
reprendre le flambeau vous le disiez
Bruno tout ça alors même si évidemment
les circonstances ne sont absolument pas
les mêmes mais cette semaine on a vu
cette infirmière qui a été assassinée
par un homme souffrant de tout
psychiatrique on a vu c'est policiers
qui sont décédés parce que un chauffard
leur est rentré dans chauffard qui
conduisait sous l'emprise d'alcool et de
stupéfiants on a vu le maire de
Saint-Brévin qui s'est senti abandonné
par l'État face à tout ça face à cette
violence Emmanuel Macron au Conseil des
ministres à employé le mot de
décibilisation est-ce que c'est un mot
approprié c'est le mot pertinent pour
vous Bruno en tout cas il fallait que le
chef de l'État met un mot sur le
sentiment qui existe lui terriblement
dans l'opinion qui est une
incompréhension face à la multiplication
de ces cas de ces drames et qui en
particulier touche des territoires de
l'État et du service public donc je
trouve que le chef de l'État
fonctionnellement il est bien dans son
rôle
à la fois de de rendre hommage de
protéger de mettre des mots sur une
réalité qui touche directement des
personnes qui très souvent dans l'ombre
sont au service du bien public donc de
ce point de là je trouve que c'est très
bien que le chef de l'État
évolue au fond on va pas dire théoriser
le mot un peu
réexagérer mais qu'il ait voulu mettre
un mot sur cette réalité
j'exclus moi personnellement l'hypothèse
que le chef de l'État ne soit préoccupé
que par de la triangulation qu'il s'agit
d'aller prendre un mot dans le
répertoire de ses adversaires politiques
pour voilà etc je pense que je suis au
d'État avait sans aucun doute plutôt en
tête l'idée de la la civilisation au
sens de la civilité et au sens d'un
sentiment qui existe dans l'opinion que
la société part un peu en vrille que le
respect de l'autorité n'est plus là
alors c'est un sentiment qui existe dans
le pignon mais régérer la politique
faire de la politique ceci beaucoup géré
des émotions des sentiments des
ressentis c'est pas forcément ce qui
existe dans la réalité mais cette
dimension est très importante
il y a une polémique autour de ce mot
mais d'ailleurs qui a été utilisé pas
seulement par Monsieur Camus Renault
Camus dans un ouvrage publié je sais
plus il y a une dizaine d'années ou une
quinzaine d'années des civilisations qui
est une notion aussi qui a été utilisée
par un très grand sociologue Norbert
Elias qui a parlé des processus de
décibilisation lui-même qui peut pas
être suspecté d'être d'extrême droite en
l'occurrence
de quoi est-ce qu'on parle mais le
problème
est-ce que c'est la hausse de la
violence ou le sentiment que la violence
est augmente dans nos sociétés mais la
décélation vous savez c'est multiples
c'est aussi peut-être la façon dont on
traite nos anciens la façon dont on a
traité nos anciens durant la crise
sanitaire il y a aussi une
responsabilité de l'État dans les
processus de décibilisation il est
évident que là Emmanuel Macron il vise
des faits qui sont des faits de violence
que l'on que le Ki qui sont exercés
contre des élus qui sont exercés contre
des infirmières qui peuvent être
exercées contre des médecins ou des ou
des pompiers ou des ou des policiers
certes qui vise des populations très
j'allais dire spécifique
mais il faudrait aussi qu'il s'interroge
lui-même sur la responsabilité qui n'est
pas la sienne seulement qui est la
responsabilité collective de l'État dans
un certain nombre aussi de phénomènes
qui ressortent là véritablement de la
responsabilité du politique et de la
société
c'est effectivement pour un politique
d'utiliser des mots et une sémantique
la droite a une mairie de faire des
propositions j'ai pas entendu un
ministre niérald Darmanin ou un autre
dire je suis d'accord avec ces
propositions et pour cause les
républicains ils font ils ont le mérite
de faire des propositions et je pense
que c'est bien pour animer le débat
qu'il les fasse on n'est pas d'accord
avec beaucoup des propositions qu'ils
font mais qu'elle a la même manière le
fait qu'ils mettent des lignes rouges
par exemple sur les sur les travailleurs
étrangers ça n'a pas ça ne me semble pas
aller dans le sens de l'opinion mais ils
ont le mérite de le faire moi ce matin
j'ai envie de passer un appel je sais
pas si j'ai rien à peine solennel c'est
un peu galvaudé mais en tout cas un
appel sérieux pour que la gauche ne soit
pas en dehors de ce débat la gauche
française la sociale démocratie la
gauche de gouvernement parapa et les
filles on sait ce qu'ils en pensent mais
la gauche de gouvernements elle a des
choses à dire sur l'immigration
d'intégration dans notre pays
voilà c'est la phrase de Livia un petit
peu dans le même temps dans ses propos
trouver compromis on entend Olivier
Véran un bon la droite elle mérite de
faire des propositions mais en gros leur
proposition ça nous convient pas et on a
vu la droite cette semaine dire nous le
projet de loi du gouvernement on va pas
le voter il y a plusieurs éléments
d'abord il faut que la droite
républicaine se recharge en crédibilité
d'opposant après la séquence retraite
donc sur la question de l'immigration
qui est un enjeu aujourd'hui
particulièrement saillant dans l'opinion
publique il faut qu'elle soit en mesure
de répondre avec une offre politique qui
soit une offre politique d'une très
grande fermeté et de ce point de vue là
clairement les propositions à la fois de
Monsieur Retailleau de Monsieur Ciotti
et de Monsieur Mardet merleix vont
clairement dans ce sens donc ça c'est un
point qui pour eux en tout cas est
extrêmement important deuxièmement moi
je vois pas comment globalement
l'exécutif dans l'état actuel des choses
et des rapports de force politique au
Parlement arrive à faire adopter un
texte sur l'immigration je le pensais
d'ailleurs de la même manière il y a
déjà quelques mois mais aujourd'hui ça
me paraît encore plus compliqué parce
que on voit bien que les rép en effet
ont fixé comme le dit Monsieur Véran des
lignes rouges avec lesquelles il ne
négocieront pas et je rappelle quand
même que Monsieur Marleix a dit que il
était prêt à aller jusqu'au dépôt d'une
motion de censure si le texte qui serait
éventuellement proposé également par le
gouvernement ne reprenait pas
pratiquement l'ensemble des propositions
des LR donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui est très compliquée pour
le gouvernement et on voit quand même
que Monsieur Véran est en difficulté
parce que bon le fait d'interpeller la
gauche sur le sujet c'est d'essayer en
effet d'aller chercher des voies
peut-être à gauche qui ne trouvera pas
manifestement à droite mais je suis pas
sûr que la nups ait envie de lui faire
ce cadeau donc il y a une impasse
politique on voit effectivement la
tentative la godie et de gauche et de
droite qui reprend à nouveau c'est à
dire d'avoir un peu enfoncé un coin à
droite avec la question des retraites
travailler davantage produire etc enfin
tout le toute la sémantique d'Emmanuel
Macron sur ce thème et puis là par
contre sur la question sécurité régalien
immigration de dire à la droite fait des
propositions mais vraiment ça va trop
loin c'est trop à droite ça nous
convient pas et d'une certaine manière
de dire la gauche puisqu'elle n'arrive
pas à faire de propositions autant
qu'elle rejoigne les notes donc ça va
être difficile quand même je partage la
vie d'Arnaud difficile de trouver une
majorité sur cette question parce que
pour les républicains c'est pas
négociable il le reste se précarer pour
eux c'est une question absolument vitale
d'incarner le régalien ils se sont fait
dépouiller sur l'économie par le
président il leur reste le régalien qui
est une question presque de de code
génétique pour les républicains avec une
très forte pression du RN et dans la
perspective des prochaines échéances
européennes qui arrivent pour eux c'est
vital depuis l'été dernier lorsque le
texte a été présenté par Gérald darmain
et Olivier du soft le texte se voulait
équilibrer en tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'il avait été présenté par l'exécutif
avec effectivement des mesures
d'intégration par le travail avec des
titres de séjour pour les secteurs en
tension et d'un côté et bien des
raccompagnements à la frontière mieux
effectués par les services de l'État
sauf que la droite depuis le début ne
veut pas de ces titres de séjour pour
eux c'est un appel d'air donc c'est
comme ça qu'ils en parlent depuis le
début d'où cet impact puisque le
gouvernement ne veut pas reculer sur un
équilibre sur ce texte et la droite elle
se montre effectivement droite dans ses
bottes sur ce texte et sur sur cette
ligne politique et d'autant que la
majorité présidentielle va avoir besoin
de la droite c'est l'autre point de
l'actualité de cette semaine ce débat
cette bataille qui a lieu déjà autour de
la proposition de loi du groupe lot pour
abroger la réforme des retraites
bataille entre majorité opposition déjà
autour de la recevabilité du texte
est-ce que elle est compréhensible pour
l'opinion cette bataille Bruno selon
vous dans son détail technique sans
aucun doute non et j'ai avec même pour
des spécialistes pour arriver à suivre
cette question c'est tout ça fait
évident on voit qu'on navigue quelque
part entre l'interprétation
des textes les de force politique dans
cette venue extrêmement compliqué c'est
pas lisible détail technique par le pian
par contre l'opinion elle a quand même
cranté sur quelque chose de très
important qui est finalement l'exécutif
n'est pas tellement si sûr de son coup
et il en a tellement peur que il est
prêt à ne pas aller jusqu'au la
discussion de cette proposition de du
groupe du groupe et c'est vrai que
l'exécutif se retrouve dans une espèce
de de choix dramatique ou aller jusqu'au
bout
et risquer une terrible humiliation
l'Assemblée nationale votant contre la
réforme des retraites qui vient juste
d'être promulguée ou alors donner le
sentiment du déni de démocratie encore
une fois peut-être que l'exécutif
considère que le dommage a déjà été fait
dans l'opinion et est prêt à aller
jusqu'au bout de son passage en
forces pour l'exécutif pour la majorité
présidentielle soit empêcher le débat
soit aller au vote avec le reste de le
perdre entre deux mots il choisissent ce
qui considère qu'en mettant le moindre
mais c'est pas du tout sûr que ça soit
le moindre que d'éviter le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que ça
enfoncer si vous voulez cette idée qu'il
existe une crise démocratique dans ce
pays et que l'on passe en force et que
l'on ne respecte pas les droits du
Parlement alors moi je rentrerai pas
dans le débat sur la question de
lirecevabilité financière de la
proposition de loi du groupe lot ce qui
m'étonne quand même c'est que malgré
tout je veux dire Madame brande pivée
dans un premier temps à accepter et il
n'y a pas vu la moindre le moindre la
moindre d'y recevabilité et
qu'aujourd'hui manifestement elle semble
changer d'avis vraisemment sous la
pression très amicale de ces partenaires
de la majorité donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui va apparaître comme
d'une certaine manière suspect dans
l'opinion publique non moi je pense
qu'il aurait mieux valu alors vous pour
répondre très franchement à votre
question je pense qu'il va aller mieux
aller au débat il va aller mieux aller
jusqu'au vote parce que ça donne le
sentiment quand même d'un exécutif qui
est comme épouvanté par sa faiblesse
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale donc
sur la ça va leur permettre si vous
voulez peut-être de franchir l'obstacle
dans le moment dans l'immédiat et ils
vont exciter ben vous voyez maintenant
on passe à autre chose la réalité c'est
que c'est un poison lent qui continue à
infuser dans les veines de la société
française dans son rapport au
gouvernement mercredi sur votre plateau
Oriane votre invité politique c'était
Charlotte cobel c'est une ministre qu'on
connaît pas très bien aller changer de
la petite enfance mais elle a eu cette
phrase quand même qui est assez
révélatrice Ali nous ferons tout pour
que ce débat n'est pas lieu et elle l'a
dit ouvertement c'était votre première
question dans l'interview un ministre
qui dit qu'il faut pas qu'un débat se
tienne au Parlement c'est quand même ça
montre ce que vous disiez c'est cette
crainte d'aller au vote et que le texte
aille au bout j'étais avec votre antenne
mercredi matin en temps écoutons la
ministre effectivement je suis un peu
tombé de ma chaise en entendant ça
tout à fait qui était une phrase qui est
quand même un peu pose question c'est
vrai que
bon la politique on sait que c'est
parfois se salir les mains pour aller
jusqu'au bout de ses idées et que
parfois on dit que la fin justifie les
moyens si on pense qu'on défend un
objectif qui lui transcende de toute
façon les moyens qu'on est prêt à
utiliser parce que c'est le bien public
dont il s'agit mais ça doit être
accompagné d'un très lourd argumentaire
sur ces au nom de la défense du bien
public et de ce point de vue là c'est
vrai que depuis le début on voit que
c'est le point faible de l'exécutif
l'explication de en quoi cette réforme
était fondamentale du point de vue de
sauvegarder le bien public auquel les
Français sont très attachés que le
système des retraites pour le moment n'a
le défaut d'explication est toujours là
ça n'était présenté que comme une mesure
budgétaire sans véritablement projet de
société
à travers cette mesure
évidemment parce que ça encore une fois
en force l'idée qu'il y a un déni de de
démocratie et puis ça pose des questions
sur la séparation des pouvoirs c'est pas
une secrétaire d'État de dire il va non
il n'y aura pas de débat donc
manifestement c'est du pain béni pour
les oppositions qui est donnée avec ce
type de déclaration
si vous motorisez rien c'est quoi les
pronostics vous sur ce qui va se jouer
en séance est-ce que il peut y avoir une
majorité en plus une majorité des
personnes présentes ce jour-là pour
voter la PLPL le au début du mois de
juin d'abord ça dépend je veux dire
qu'elle va être la position de Madame
brande Pivet sur ce sujet moi ce que
j'ai compris c'est que elle allait quand
même faire jouer l'irrecevabilité alors
est-ce que c'est faisable ou pas d'abord
il faut que
la commission des affaires sociales doit
se prononcer on va voir s'il y aura une
majorité pour défendre la position de
les recevabilité au sein d'un commission
des affaires sociales il faudra suivre
de très près le vote des députés LR en
la matière parce qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de majorité s'il y a pas le vote
des députés LR ensuite si on va au vote
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
la loi toutes les chances d'être adoptée
puisqu'on est sur une majorité simple
donc il y a le groupe yote en tout cas
quand on discute avec les parlementaires
du groupe ils sont assez assez
optimistes pour la présidente de
l'Assemblée situation historique un peu
très difficile d'un côté elle doit
incarner son rôle de président de
l'Assemblée c'est-à-dire une sorte de
neutralité elle est au service de son
assemblée et puis de l'autre côté
fonctionnellement également elle doit
faire respecter le droit le droit
constitutionnel et donc de ce point là
c'est vrai que c'est une situation assez
exceptionnelle un peu historique je
dirais même et qui sans doute fera fra
date dans les annales du parlementarisme
en France
elle dit que finalement on peut pas
immédiatement abroger une loi que le
Parlement vient de d'adopter elle se met
aussi dans une position de défense du
Parlement avec cet argumentaire
du point de vue de la lisibilité et de
ce que ça peut vouloir dire aux yeux de
l'opinion qui est le sentiment que le
Parlement le gouvernement prenne des
décisions mais qui peuvent être remises
en cause quelques semaines après c'est
vrai que ça fait passer un message qui
qui on va dire voilà qui est très confus
quoi oui sauf que si vous voulez les
parlementaires qui s'opposent au texte
de loi pourront toujours mettre en avant
le fait que cette loi était adoptée sans
véritable discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale quelle a été adoptée par un
49-3 qu'on est allé
on n'est jamais allé jusqu'au bout de la
lecture et qu'on a utilisé tous les
j'allais dire aux articles possibles et
imaginables du parlementarisme
rationalisé comme jamais sous la
Cinquième République pour arriver au
concept à faire adopter
[Musique]
on n'est pas sur non on n'est pas
surtout sur un retour à la quatrième
parce que le retour à la quatrième
c'était un régime d'assemblée et où le
parlementarisme n'était pas du tout
rationalisé il était largement débridé
en l'occurrence c'est pas du tout le
même c'est pas du tout le même type de
régime mais non non on est véritablement
si vous voulez dans un j'allais dire
presque dans un durcissement dans un
raidissement de l'utilisation des outils
qui contraignent le Parlement sous la
Cinquième République c'est plutôt cela à
quoi on assiste aujourd'hui mais avec un
point avec un poids énorme d'un petit
groupe
qui devient un groupe charnière le
groupe culotte du point de vue
effectivement du fonctionnement du du
Parlement et des interactions entre les
différentes institutions ça c'est
vraiment passionnant parce que quand on
remonte le fil du temps on voit qu'au
tout début l'exécutif souhaitait aller
jusqu'à l'examen du fameux article 7 qui
n'a pas pu dit-il lié
comportement dit-il des oppositions
d'avoir déposé trop d'amendements donc
on se retrouve dans une situation qui
est avec plein de paradoxes sur les
interactions entre les institutions et
on suivra tout ça ça fera on n'en doute
pas l'actualité de la semaine prochaine
également on en reparle le vendredi vous
le savez on vous emmène à la découverte
de notre patrimoine et on va vous
emmener voir les jardins de Claude Monet
à Giverny dans l'Eure ils ont ouvert
leurs portes le premier avril dernier
véritable œuvre d'art ils attirent
chaque année des milliers de visiteurs
fascinés par les couleurs et la variété
de fleurs dont le fameux nénuphar
maintes fois un pain par l'artiste c'est
une section a suivi l'artisan de ce
tableau vivant Jean-Marie avisar c'est
le chef jardinier
[Musique]
il arpente ses massifs fleuris depuis 35
ans Jean-Marie est bizarre le chef
jardinier de la maison de Claude Monet à
Giverny a fait ses armes dans ses allées
il est aujourd'hui le principal artisan
de la luxuriance de ces jardins qu'il
fait évoluer en fonction des saisons
comment ouvre le 1er avril on peut pas
mettre tout de suite ses plantes parce
que du premier avril chez nous jusqu'au
15 mai peut geler encore et ce plan là
si gèle elles sont foutues donc il faut
il faut attendre le 15 mai donc pour
attendre le 15 mai on met penser Giroflé
etc qu'on plante en hiver et maintenant
qu'il y a plus de risques de gel on
plante les odeurs
est aussi le gardien de l'esprit voulu
par Claude Monet
on va chercher les plantes en
choisissant un peu comme une palette de
peinture les couleurs de plantes qui
nous intéressent à associer et ensuite
on les pose dans les massifs un peu
comme si on faisait une peinture par
petites touches et par voilà par
association de couleurs par Nuance etc
quand le peintre a acheté cette maison
en 1883 l'extérieur n'était qu'une
grande pelouse Claude Monet en a fait
son lieu d'inspiration
il était pas très connu donc il faisait
il a fait son jardin avec sa famille les
enfants étaient au travail sa femme etc
mais rapidement quand il a commencé à
vendre des toiles il a il s'est entouré
il avait un chef jardinier il avait
vraiment une équipe de jardiniers à son
service
en 1926
quand le terrain est récupéré en 1977
par la fondation qui porte son nom il ne
reste presque rien du jardin
impressionniste du peintre il a fallu
tout reconstruire
à la restauration il était vraiment à
l'abandon le jardin et du coup le
conservateur de l'époque
on recherchait tous les documents
possibles toutes les photos il existait
une vidéo du jardin d'eau
tous les tous les témoignages de gens
qui qui à l'époque avait encore connu le
jardin à l'époque de monnaie et donc ils
ont réussi à recréer des endroits à
l'identique par rapport à
l'époque de Claude Monet
copie conforme du siècle précédent les
jardins de Giverny attirent aujourd'hui
des milliers de touristes entre avril et
octobre avec une star les nymphéas des
Muses pourtant bien capricieuses
tous les jours il y a quelqu'un qui
nettoie la surface qui coupe l'herbe
dans le fond qui retaille les nymphéas
parce que les nymphéas si on les laisse
faire ils vont couvrir tous les temps on
verra plus l'eau donc si on veut les
garder comme sur le tableau en tâche
comme ça il faut en des feuilles
toujours toujours s'en occuper
près de 250 fois par Claude Monet qui
avait fait de son jardin doux son sujet
de prédilection
et voilà pour ce magnifique jardin avec
des Nymphéas Quentin
[Rires]
[Musique]
et on commence par cette forte émotion à
roubaillère
on lit cet hommage à trois enfants de la
République à la Une de Nord éclair vous
le voyez à gauche ici un titre similaire
dans l'autre journal du groupe La Voix
du Nord parler d'eux pour rendre hommage
à leur destin cette citation d'Emmanuel
Macron que l'on voit à la Une à propos
de ces trois policiers de tués par une
collision par un chauffard dimanche le
chef de l'État leur a remis la Légion
d'honneur à titre posthume hier dans ce
drame deux enfants perdent leur père un
petit du 1 an et un bébé qui doit naître
ils seront pupilles de la nation à
annoncer Emmanuel Macron la presse
régionale revient sur l'autre drame des
derniers jours l'assassinat d'une
infirmière à Reims
de Karen Mezino l'infirmière poignardée
se tiendront jeudi 1er juin dans la
presse on lit ces questionnements sur la
sécurité des hôpitaux à l'image de ce
que l'on voit ici elle a une de l'Est
éclair on voit que le centre spécialisé
de 3 par exemple il travaille déjà sur
cette question même d'avant le drame une
équation compliquée entre accueil des
patients des familles et protections des
personnels on attend des nouvelles
annonces dans les prochaines semaines de
la part des ARS sans les agences
régionales de santé organes dans le
Télégramme on revient sur cette
polémique à propos des SDF de
l'Île-de-France de Paris d'Île-de-France
reloger dans plusieurs régions un
journal breton qui parle effectivement
d'un Broglio dans la région où vous
voyez sur la base du volontariat des
personnes sans abri ils sont invitées à
prendre des navettes pour être relogées
dans les départements l'idée pour le
gouvernement est de desserrer la
pression je cite sur l'île de France il
est tombant dans le journal mais
certains ils voient plutôt une manière
de disperser la pauvreté aussi pour la
rendre moins visible avant les JO de
2024 sauf que visiblement et bien en
Bretagne les structures sont déjà
saturées c'est ce que raconte le journal
et c'est sans doute que le début de
cette polémique on passe à un
anniversaire l'un des plus beaux jours
du sport français en toute objectivité
il y a 30 ans quand même gagner la Ligue
des Champions on dirait que vous êtes
sûrs
[Musique]
avec cette une exceptionnelle on l'a
c'est la une en fait du journal Le
Provençal qui est l'aîné de la Provence
de 1993 et on le voit aussi aujourd'hui
toute la ville de Marseille qui se
prépare à célébrer cette anniversaire
des 18 heures sur le parvis de l'Hôtel
de Ville le match sera même rediffusé
Oriane et ça ça vous plaît beaucoup
avant un craquage exceptionnel de
fumigène le long d'une chaîne humaine 20
km de fumigène
content pour terminer allez on termine
avec cette une qui m'a beaucoup plu
puisqu'on est à la veille d'un week-end
de trois jours pour de nombreux Français
le progrès qui titres à Lyon évadez-vous
les possibilités sont extrêmement
nombreuses en selon week-end de la
Pentecôte alors soufflons un bon coup
surtout face à l'actualité un peu voilà
même très triste des derniers jours
merci Quentin une nouvelle formule de la
revue politique et parlementaire Arnaud
sexe corps et politique des liaisons
tumultueuses oui une nouvelle formule
vous savez que la rue politique et
parlementaire aura l'année prochaine 130
ans donc il fallait renaître d'une
certaine manière c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire alors on mettait toujours le
principe du dossier dossier qui en effet
peut-être plus détonnant cette fois-ci
contenu des thèmes et puis beaucoup de
rubriques et c'est une nouveauté
beaucoup plus de respiration et
d'ailleurs à responsable de rubrique sur
la rubrique pouvoir qu'il est temps que
Bruno Contrex
on aura l'occasion d'en parler un petit
peu tous les vendredis merci beaucoup
Arnaud d'avoir été avec nous merci Bruno
d'avoir une telle merci Quentin on se
retrouve bah mardi du coup puisque c'est
un long week-end et pour voir ou revoir
cette émission rendez-vous sur
publicena.fr très bon weekend
[Musique]